and he'll talk about randomiz
synar Sol thank you Ali and thank you
for inviting me to to come give a talk
here so I'm going to talk about
asynchronous linear solvers for
symmetric positive definite matrices and
I want to start with some motivation why
we are looking on as synchronous method
so I'm going to give two motivations one
is more related to applications and big
data and is I'm going to ask you a
question so we want to solve axal B A is
symetri positive definite it's large
it's sparse and we want to use an
iterative method because the Matrix is
too big to do a direct method and it has
structure that is not very good for
direct methods and the question should
we use gadel or CG I mean gadel is a
very old technique it's a it was
invented it's based on relaxation or
fixation invented before CG and usually
it's not much use today because if you
look at the theory you you know that
that CG would convergence square root of
the condition number there's also
dependence on the Epsilon which is log
one over Epsilon which I'm kind of
ignoring now but
gadel if you take a randomized version
of it not the the the the classical one
which I I'll I'll give details on the
randomize in a few slides if you look if
you do the convergence it's only the
time the amount of iterations is
proportional to the condition number so
if the condition number is Big this can
be a big difference so why would you
want to use a gaus sadel well you then
try it on on a metrix for example we
have because this big data I'm taking
for I took a metrix from Big Data and
this is a metrix from doing some
regression on social media data and in
general the results do much the theory
you really see that CG is is is
progressing much faster I didn't
continue with Beyond 20 200 iterations
but it's clear the trend I mean if you
if you continue to write I mean CG will
continue will bypass the the randomized
G sadelia which is which is stuck I mean
it's on the slightly below 10 to the^
minus 3 it will continue to go to very
high accuracies but what interesting is
that if you look at the start you tend
to see the random the ga sadel base
method this very cheap small iteration
method they tend to make a lot of
progress early
on and what happens is that in many
applications specifically for the
application we were looking on here this
is all the accuracy you need if you go
beyond that you not get anything in
terms of the of the downstream use for
how this solution is used so if you do
just 10 iterations take this solution
you get in all you you can op to get
from solving this equation but if you do
10 iteration of CG you you're up here
and you lose a lot in terms of the of
dation so you need to continue up to
here and if you continue here of course
you're not get anything so you really
want to be around here and to take this
method that it do does a lot of fast
initial progress and you but of course
as Sian mentions mentioned to have good
software you need to paralyze that and
and there's quite a few ways to paralyze
it we looked at an as synchronous way to
paraly it which is I think quite easy an
easy way to do it and and we can show
that it gets you good results so I'm
going to give you a second motivation
and this is more like a well-known trade
it's not like not a concrete example of
an application is that CPU clock speeds
have reached the limit and we have to
use more processors but uh as we get to
really large processor counts we know
that there's there's a problem with
communication and between those
processors and spec specifically there
is a problem with scalability because of
synchronization points that if you have
P processor you do need to do order of
log of P to just to synchronize them so
if p is very large then you you're
trying you're paying a lot for the
synchronization points and because of
this Trends asynchronous method are
becoming more and more attractive you do
want to avoid the synchronization points
as as you go to i processor
accounts so asynchronous numerical
methods are pretty old and they're
probably the oldest well the idea is
basically must say that is to avoid the
idal time but just letting processor
progress without explicitly
synchronizing between them just using
maybe information that is a bit old and
the idea was perhaps first suggested in
69 with chaotic relaxation and since
then it been applied to many to lot of
applications but they were never really
consider mainstream and not very popular
compared to Method like CG or other or
things that are synchronous and there
might be quite there's a few reasons for
that and I'm G going to give you my take
on it um the the issue is that the
analysis is usually based on fixed PR
duration so you can f you can only prove
a convergence in the limit and that's
and and that's a little problematic
because you don't know how it behaves in
practice and really there's examples of
of metrices where do in method converge
very slowly so we we don't understand
about them the concurrency is usually
not enough to see any benefit but they
they are much slower than the sing
counterpart so it's not very attractive
and finally that's even more severe
restriction problem is that there they
of the traditional method often Place
very severe restrictions on the metrices
that they can prove convergence for
example D dominance like discussed
previous slide is one of those
conditions where we know where it was
known that various as synchronous method
converge but more General like take
symmetric positive definite metries
without any structure then we don't
there were not known algorithms for
that but now there's more recent work
and I'm going to give detail a few that
are relevant there's some work on in a
distribute setting on agents that's not
like the talk yesterday that's not the
setting we are talking about it's a
different setting we have we are looking
at the Shared memory or distributed
memory set
but from that line of work there's one
method that is more related to what we
are presenting and it's based on it's on
synchronizing clocks Bas on the kmas
method the same method C discussed in PR
slide and that's a similar some
similarity to the method we are going to
describe because we are using gadel
which is related to the kmas much more
relevant for this talk is the recent
work on ogal which is basically asinos
spiralization of stochastic gr and
descent there's a convergence rate
analysis you can say how how how the
asynchronous
effects for a shared memory model and
our analysis is inspired by this but
it's significantly different and we have
much better convergence for this
specific problem of solving linear
equation so I'm going to uh give details
on a ningle solver for General semetic
positive definite matrices we can show
it converges in a provable rate and its
condition number it's linear and it's a
randomized algorithm so all error bounds
are going to be an expectation
so I will start with some background on
randomized gadel what that means and
then give the algorithm some experiment
so let let's start with a randomiz G and
I will explain that using some
um basically a very simple iteration an
almost obvious one especially after the
first talk today which is basically
doing coordinate
descent maybe doing coord set on a on a
on on this function but let's start with
a more general setting where we we have
a and x and we have some direction
vectors D and we always want to do steps
in in those Direction vectors which I'm
not specifying them yet so we do this
kind of equation where here we have some
step size gamma subj and we have this
this formula why why is this for where
comes this formula well this is the
formula that will minimize the the error
in the a norm of The Next Step this is
analytic question if you just do that
that's the minimization of this one so
it really makes sense if you agrey to to
do these steps in in if you select a
direction just to use these gamas but
the question is of course how to select
this uh Direction vectors and actually
most method to do solve iterative solve
linear equations can be cast as this
kind of iteration even CG just as a
clever way of selecting these Direction
vectors and one simple way to select
them is to just do around Robin on the
coordinates just look at the identity
vectors where you just take the first
identity Vector the second identity
vector so Force and and cycle and this
if you kind of look at the equation long
enough and try to figure out you'll see
that this is equivalent for an iteration
of the classical algorith of gel it's a
different way to describe gel but it is
an
equivalent an equivalent one and what's
nice about these Direction vectors is
that the iterations are very small and
cheap you need only one entry of the
residual of um of this guy of the
difference between b and a * X so you
need only one row to look at one row of
the metrix to compute this guy and then
you can do this step very
efficiently okay so
um so how this works well to analyze you
can analyze using classical techniques
in fixed pations but if you want but a
new
um somewhat more attractive way that
relates things to a condition number is
to look at a randomized version of it
where you select the direction vectors
not not in a cyclic way you kind of
select them with some probability the
probability should be proportional to
the to the diagonal values and then if
you do if you if you use this kind of
way to select the direction vectors you
can bound the expected a nor of the
error after M steps using basically
reducing by some factor that is smaller
than one so you have a linear
convergence but what really governs the
the the convergence is this ratio
between of the smallest I value and the
the trace of the metrix which is the sum
of the IG values so the running time is
going to be proportional to the inverse
of this guy which is the trace divided
by the smallest I values and see the
trace is bounded by n times the lar
largest value number of iterations is
bounded by n times the condition number
but n iterations is about equivalent to
one Matrix Vector multiplication so this
is like equivalent to basically order of
the condition number of doing as much
operation in CG here which basically the
metrix vector is the most expensive
operation
so this is the way to analyze this is
the analysis and I'm going to go quickly
through the analysis because it's going
to be useful later on when we analyze
the asynchronous method it's a very
simple analysis the it can be put in one
slide but there's a few more details
maybe but basically this is all the
analysis basically now we are going to
assume that from now on that a is a unit
diagonal we can always achieve That by
rescanning The Matrix and then basically
we need we want to look at the step size
which is basically this expression with
equal probabilities and then you can
just do very simple albic manipulation
so that the aor after J J plus monation
is related to the aor after J iteration
minus some term that is positive all is
positive that's what we progress but
again now this is a Rand of varable so
we can take if fix the residual it's
basically the average entry in the
residual and but this guy we can always
bound using the igen
values like this and then take
expectation of both sides and then we
get the bounce on the expectation on how
much we progress and we take the lower
bound and plug it in here and just get
the bound with this sky and now we also
given an upper bound we can bound how
fast we can progress this is of course
not something you usually want to do but
when you're going to analyze that synr
method this is going to be important
actually okay so now we're are going to
get to the as version so before that I'm
going to give some P code of the non of
the synchron
method so this is just AB code basically
you just at each you say select a random
entry you read the entries of x that you
need to compute the step size you
compute it and then you just do the
update and now I'm going to describe the
as version it's a very small very easy
variant of this basically I'm just
taking this algorithm and I'm executing
on all processors and all processor are
going to share the vector X but all of
them are going to do not share anything
else except the have the same share X in
Shar memory that they're going to
operate so this is the algorithm I said
all our processor execute the same
algorithm and I'm going to do two small
modification of the algorithm first of
all I'm going to require the updates
here to be Atomic so you can do that
using usually this using Hardware but it
means that no nothing can interfere in
the middle by when you're doing these
operations and I'm also going to add a
small step size here beta which has to
be smaller than one to show convergence
but it can actually be quite close to
one so this is the two small
modifications and and now we want to
analyze us so to do that we need to
write iteration in some meaningful way
so the rights are Atomic so we can order
the updates in some in some order some
Ser serialization of the updates and we
can write some fixures iteration X subj
which is basically all the all the
updates that that happened up until the
J after J iterations basically some
linearization and now what's what
happens in the in the ASN method is that
when you reading the entes here on the
line
before some of the updates that happen
before that are going to to be read you
reading the vectors you you're going to
see updated values and some are not some
maybe updated you read them before they
were updated or something like that so
you can always
describe a set of K of J K of J of
updates that are consistent with the
vector you read the vector you read must
be cons because the the operations are
Atomic must be considered with some set
of updates so you can have some Maximum
set and then you can always describe
your iteration in terms of this
additional kind of um nonexisting
iterations that are depend on set of
update you can describe X after set a
specific set of updates as occur as
basically just taking this updates and
you can describe your iteration as in
terms of the the residual on that
iteration that actually never happened
but you can describe your iteration in
terms of it so you can write some useful
expression for how how XJ + one looks as
a function of X this doesn't work
anymore XJ okay now you want to analyze
this and of course you have to make some
assumption because if you allow some
delay some updates to never be read you
they will you have upate very slow
convergence so you need to assume there
is some bed asynchronism which we say if
we have a parameter to that really says
that all updates that are older than to
will be read when you
get will will be read at at a specific
iteration which is this is just formal
way to say that every iteration that is
only enough will be read and of course
you need and you need another assumption
is that H you're not really completely
adversarial because if you kind of said
the KJ is why when you know the random
choices here then that that can really
mess up your convergence but it's not
it's not a realistic assumption so we
allow KJS to be arbitrary but they don't
but they cannot depend on the actual
random choice
okay so now I'm going to be slightly
more technical in the analysis in a few
slides apologize for that so we you can
do the the analysis starts by just doing
some algebraic manipulation to write
there after j+1 iteration as a function
of what happens after gations plus some
progress here that is always positive
and then some additional terms that that
isn't always positive that's something
that really come from the synchronicity
it measures the vector that we would
have wanted to see and the vector that
we actually
see so we have some progress that is
positive but this can be negative but
the idea is that since these two guys
are different by only to coordinates and
Matrix a is also Spar so so this guy can
be in many cases will be zero because it
the entries that are non zero a might
not be the entries that are non zero in
that specific code because we're
selecting a specific so with that
probability this guy is going to be
going to be zero with other probabilties
is going be actually bad for us it's
going to slow us down but the the idea
is to try to bound this negative
effect so now you of course take
expectation and you have this expect you
have reduction in the expectation and
and some term that now is positive
because we take an upper bound and this
guy is depends on on basically on this m
on this thing that is a measure of
basically how sparse The Matrix is
relative to the side because we have one
of an N here but this guy is always
smaller than n but if the Matrix is spse
this guy is going to be one over n so we
have a very
small very small component here another
nice thing is that this the progress
depend is proportional to Beta but the
but the damage here is proportional to
Beta Square so we can always set beta to
be small enough that this guy will be
bigger than this guy but and the final
observation is really useful is that the
guys that appear here in the expectation
are basically guides that appeared in
previous situations because this this
one can be bigger than this one but it's
always much smaller because of these
coefficients than the progress we made
at previous situations so we kind of
need to basically the kind of
compensation is the progress made in in
some itation by the damage that is
causing this situation the way you can
do that is basically now take a sum just
aggregate write the error after keration
as a function of the first iteration and
all the progresses that were made and
then we can bound the progress by some
lower bound and get this expiration on
the expected error of after mation this
is still a little difficult to analyze
because we have here only upper bounds
on this guys so we cannot really
show enough progress but the way you
need to do this is again like I said you
need the the upper bound you need to
show there's enough progress because you
only have upper you only have upper
bound you need to show that the progress
is not too fast so because what happens
is that if since your progressor is is
proportional to the error after in the
previous situation if these guys are too
small then you're not showing any
progress so we you need to bound these
guys from below that's came that comes
from the slide before that I earlier on
that I showed some lower bouns on the
some upper bouns on the rate of the
progress so you use this guy and you can
show that after you did enough iteration
which is proportional to the to the
number to n then you have some reduction
in the expected error by some con factor
that depends on the condition and some
some consider that really captures the
what the asynchronism does so hopefully
if if P of if row row two is small then
this guy is going to be
small so if you do enough Tiny Steps
then the expector stops grows down
decreases by some constant factor and
then we can occasionally synchronize the
thread in order to reduce the expected
error but of course we don't don't
always really want to synchronize this
is like we synchronize every anation
which is not that bad we don't need to
synchronize every every one every
iteration but we are still going to
synchronize about the same time amount
of time as we are going to do like CG so
you can walk a little harder and I'm not
going to give the details and you can
show you can show a bound without any
additional synchronization the the terms
are much more
complicated so this is the results and
it appears in the
paper
and now can do additional assumption if
you really want to improve so here you
have a dependence of to squared which is
basically the square square of the
number of processors and here you have
enough to cubed you can improve this if
you are if you if you kind of ince
somehow that there you read entries that
are always consistent that that the
interest that you read are consist with
some
iteration then you can show an improv
bound which depends only on to so you
are linear in number of processors and
then you basically have a weak scaling
regime but of course enforcing this is
kind a little hard it might it might be
maybe some Hardware that allows you to
do that maybe transaction memory but
it's still not easy to enforce this
but this this analysis is not completely
useless in the sense that because the
Matrix is very sparse usually the ENT
that you read will be consist with some
iteration so the real Behavior if you
don't do anything the real Behavior will
not be this but it will but sorry it
will not actually will not be this as
well so it will be something between the
two but in in terms of the bound you
have to make this assumption if you want
to S St the
bound sorry so now some experiments um
this is again the same metrix before
rising from social media analysis and we
use a single blue genin Q node that that
are 16 course each one of them can do
fourway upper threading so it there
total of maximum amount of 64 threads
that we can spawn here and now we take
this Matrix and we and we and we run it
and again the y- axis is the running
time and so lower is better and it's a
it's a logarithmic scale and also the
number of processor L scale so we see
that the Asos method as we expect
because everybody is independent really
has linear speed up and it continues to
around for 48 time 48 times faster at 64
thread and consider that some of these
threads are virtual I mean we only have
16 16 actual course so this is this is
pretty good speed up CG is actually
parying pretty well as well but as as a
number processor gets up you kind of see
that it deviates from the from the
linear speed up and it and if you
probably if you if you add more threads
then you could B is T tends to flat out
and at 64 thread we the as method is
twice faster and here I'm doing 10
iteration because that's all we need for
the
application and some okay so are you
paying that in terms of the residual for
using the N synon method well you are
paying something the Theory shows that
but you're not paying a lot so the black
line is what happens if you just use
randomized G sadel on this metrix no no
asynchronicity you do as synch method
it's 48 times slower but it it gives you
slightly better results after 10
iterations it gives you around 10 to
the^ minus 3 and the as is slightly
higher but it's still the same order of
magnitude it's not a big difference that
will
affect uh how you are going to use the
solution so conclusion we have a new
approach foring linear solvers it uses
randomization to gracefully handle the
non-deterministic as synchronous
Behavior now we don't if you look
through the slides we never made some
assumption on the symmetric positive
definite Matrix we only assume that it
is spse enough to so that there's not
too much um Collision when you're doing
theing sitation but we're not imposing
any structure or limitation on it so we
don't need something like dag that we
can apply it to a wide R of matrices and
we just took one I just took one
application here that usually if you use
traditional method they they cannot even
show convergence for
it and for many for most metrices okay
this maybe a slightly strong claim but
for many matrices it will it will
converge if the matrices are relatively
sparse it's linear conver ter of the
condition number there's some slowdown
due to the to the to the asnr but it's
it's not too
big and for this Square you can probably
you can generalize this to the
randomized km and get similar conversion
and San discussed Tiny Tiny Steps about
for paration but as synchronicity can
maybe handle that so that's that's one
some of the idea of using a synchron
enity to make to use these Tiny Steps
but in parall basically and that's
all
questions on the randomized kar or so
I on you're talking about something else
asynchronous CED so I saw he gave some
talk about that but I never saw a paper
so I don't know the details he told he I
met him a few in in February and
mentioned that is working on
that is it out is it on arive or
something okay so I look for
it examp matx I think it is 1, perow it
is yeah something like that did you
choose purose no no this is a real
applic side I think then you sp is
better for the so so no no that that
metrics are wanted I wanted a metrix
that it really made that really doing
make I wanted a metrix that it makes
sense to do this uh weak iterations that
really get the benefit and I had some
guy who did this analysis on on social
media I cannot say exactly what the
analysis is but this is the metrix he
had and I said this is the metrix that
is good for this method and it was
turned out to be good for this method
so